do you know what my people call this  past year  the long halloween  the holiday killer's covering his tracks  i'm here to cut a deal you want falcone  and i got plenty on him  heads i'll take it your father went into  business with the roman  and how many innocent lives did he end  up trading for it  where'd you find them you're not going  to like it  when you were coming up you wouldn't  have thought to hire freaks  times change it's hard to believe the  man who stood on this roof and made that  promise  would cross the line everyone's invited  to this party  twinkle twinkle little bat how i wonder  what you're doing  what is this judgment day  you